thank you like to thank the organizers
for having me and this is john work with
my former postdoc
antoni joseph who is now at warmer
research lab
so since this workshop is from theory to
practice i definitely have a lot of
practice and i'm conjectured and i'm
going the furthest to practice for the
whole workshop and you guys can tell me
whether it's the case by friday
so um
i will motivate what we do uh with my
classroom with a project with a bunch of
people maybe oh my student studio wu and
the scientist at uh
berkeley yourself latino project and um
urban with the collaborator and humans
and sue sanika
so i think this life is not necessary
for this workshop
so yourself level a good reason has been
one of the model organisms
for biology to study
and has very small short life cycle
and
the genetic mechanism at least at the
beginning level very similar to humans
and it's very easy to maintain the lab
so uh has been used a lot
and the um
ibo sue sanneker's lab has been
collecting
relatively large image database for
embryos of
drosophila and what you see here is is
that you can think this as gene
expression intensities of this gene
called tailless
on this embryo
and tailless means that if you kind of
knock out this gene the fly won't have
tail so the name is quite telling okay
so this is a very unique data set in the
sense that you have the spatial
distribution or layout of the gene
expressions relative to the embryo and
most of the other genetic genomic
dataset have like rna seq doesn't have
this spatial information so the idea is
to use this co-occurrence of spatial
information try to figure out which gene
interacts with which
and we have seven thousand genes
with
this doesn't work
one thousand stay embryo because we have
replicates and you kind of see that they
have different shapes
and this is pretty early stage
and the goal is to understand gene
interactions and localized
and try to understand how organs are
formed
so this is sorry where does
the data set available yes it's an open
data set it's a public domain and
fortunately or unfortunately there
haven't been too many paper they would
love to have more people use it so if
you're interested email me i'll be happy
to point you to the where the
database is
so this is a known
kind of clustering of segregation
segmentation of the embryo based on some
very old technology of laser ablation so
you basically try to cut with laser and
see what happens
and you can see that for early
development it's mainly about food
and skin
with neuron development so that's what
happens when you first have the embryos
you try to make sure you can process the
food and
you have the skin the shelter and then
you have neuron some intelligence
so one test is this is called a faith
map
so with this co-occurrence of different
gene expressions can we recover
something like this
and
so first we use this
gene expression images to form a graph
so let's think that
the way we can register and line up all
the images that's also non-trivial and
become pixels they all lined up those
stacked up so for each pixel you think
you have a whole vector of the intensity
of different gene expressions at that
location okay that's the signature of
that
um
okay okay so the nodes will be the
pixels
and we're going to
put an edge between the two nodes or
pixels if there are a lot of code
expressions of genes that means they
seem to be
related because a lot of
transcription gene
genes are working together at that two
locations simultaneously
so we're making assumption basic
co-occurrence means interaction which
might not be the case but this is
uh
for this data a necessary assumption
question after that can we recover this
map
so we have that's what i said right you
have all these gene expressions
and
we after some normalization and
centering we
just look at the inner product
and we basically cut the 90 percentile
above that we call it one connected and
zero otherwise so the highly current
pistols with high core current gene
signatures we say they're connected
and now if we use that data with zero
one as a graph and we use i
regular just the usual
spectral classroom that's what you end
up with very skilled
it doesn't look like the fade metal at
all right that that'll be the classroom
coming out if we just given
the number of classes is eight
if you use the regularized version which
i'll tell you then get something a lot
more similar to what you saw in the feed
map
okay so this just show you that
regularization does help
and then we try to explain why
you can identify
the different parts with names
and this is not satisfying at all right
it's completely skewed
because the small clusters skill
the big clusters that's what i think
people know is a problem
and
in general we have
community detection and for this
workshop early papers at least you can
go back to the field of paper 1973
and their more recent works from both cs
and stack community
so remember i have
made a zero one matrix depending on how
co-occurring two gene expressions i mean
two pixels share the same gene
expressions
and
each node for me is a pixel location
and this is just the usual degree matrix
d
and you do the normalized version
to get the laplacian
well i'm not doing the i minus because
the decomposition is the same
so you can have different versions of it
and we're taking this version
and for
people who don't know spectral
clustering this is like a
two slice of tutorial you have
this simulated
zero-watt matrix
and you can do permutation to make them
clustered
and you
take the first and second eigenvector of
the laplacian and you can see two
clusters
very nicely they are the same except now
i see there are two clusters here just
they're just data points and you do
k-means
okay
and
i already said that
special classes become very popular and
many
papers
not exhaustive here to analyze under
different conditions you can
assume like money for learning
type of
assumptions and here i take
the more um
stochastic block model and analyze the
spectral clustering and the stochastic
block model more like a graph model
and in
2013 paper by amini chen biko and lavina
petra it's actually here they propose a
very simple but effective regularization
you simply just lift the boat
on the adjacency matrix you add a
constant matrix this is just for
normalizing it's just a constant matrix
this is the one matrix and this is
normal line regularization parameter
okay so just leave the vote
for all the json c matrix
entries and then pretend that's your
data of adjacency mate and do the same
thing
for the plugin everything just become
the same okay so you just add a little
constant to the adjacency matrix
and then proceed to do the flashing
okay and then you take the top
eigenvectors and you do k-means and
that's the regularized vector clustering
and there's another version that you
only add the constant to the degree
matrix not adjacency matrix so in
practice actually might be a little
better that's what i hear i haven't had
a lot of experience okay so you have
similar analysis in this line of
research
what's the motivation but
communication um
people probably know better what's the
motivation but
from what i can tell you have basically
reduced a lot of noise in the uh
adjacency matrix the small clusters get
you don't have signature for that and
then you can concentrate on the big
communities because the small cluster
can always be
has known to be problematic to destroy
as i show you with the faith map the big
clusters
so this way you kind of
um
don't play those small clusters
and the stochastic broad module has been
mentioned it's the simplest model i
think it's also called the planted
partition model
in the cs literature you assume you have
independent
edges drawn
with different probabilities
uh independent from bernoullis so just a
toss and then the probabilities can be
generally different but usually you need
a separation of the probabilities for
the blocks
these probabilities cannot be too close
the p's and q's cannot be too close
otherwise you don't have a block
structure
and this is just again a sample and then
you can
see that
things you see this vlog type of uh
adjacency matrix
and i will focus on two clusters
yes
two questions first of all when you say
performance uh increases when you add
the the all ones matrix i'm sorry what
so you're adding the all ones matrix
to the adjacency matrix so this is
improving the performance as in the
result obtained or also the
the running high performance
the running time is the same
yeah but um so is this equivalent to
just increasing all edge weights by
yeah yeah
so you don't have zero weight anymore
you have a small weight
you kind of just add the constant to
everybody yeah so we also tried on just
the uh
i think we um
i think we get probably similar results
but the thing is um
it's harder to see if you have a lot of
edges right when you do that and we also
kind of do a bit denoising
by thresholding
yeah
yeah
i i think if you cut not as high as when
you just get similar result but if you
don't i think you might have two noise
results and also it's hard to visualize
just too many links yeah
so i don't think it should be too
sensitive to the 90
but i don't think i think you do want to
scratch out a bit
so what we're going to show you is to
give you some insight on why the
regularization work by uh some bounds so
suppose you have two clusters
and
this is a simulated stochastic block
model with two blocks and
if you do and
just a regular spectral clustering
you can see that
you have
you can still have good separation but
the variability
of
this direction around the second uh egg
and back direction much bigger than
after regularization
okay so this is just same thing as any
when we do a lot of regularization in
statistics machine learning is really
reduced variability and you can actually
show that the same choice of the two
actually stay the same
okay so the only thing you you you are
introducing to reduce variability with
the same distance than you gain
but there's a sweet spot right if you
add too much
a big tile then everything becomes
constant you lose the signature of the
cluster right so apparently you don't
want to add too much
this is selected
without message right so there's a sweet
spot you don't if you don't add much
nothing will change if you add a lot you
lose the signal of the community and you
want to be in the middle too
to really reduce the variance but still
retain the distance
and you do k means on this
because the same problem you have
you know um
you end up with putting this together
because for here
the cross cluster distance as in the
previous talk mentioned that it's
smaller than within the cluster so you
messed up
here you don't have that problem because
you tighten them up
and
yes
yeah just try to compare it yeah you
have to fix some
uh after like downstream analysis yes
so if you didn't regularize the trouble
would be that some of the rows might
have very small di and the inverse makes
it unstable right yeah so instead you
could just
try you know cap off the entries of d
inwards just as well instead of adding
yeah the other one only to work with the
d the other regularization
there's another line we just because
we're close to
two
futures group so we're analyzing this
version
you could do the other way to just do
um
regularize the d in some way yeah
i think similar it's very similar
analysis can be done
so um
here's just some notation
this is just the data version of the
regularized spectral clustering and use
v as the
matrix the top two eigenvectors of the
sample version the regularized spectral
clustering
and you can similarly define population
versions of the same quantity right you
take the probability
matrix instead of the adjacency matrix
and also do the regularization and you
have parallel laplacian and so forth for
the population quantities
and
you um
just recall this is the sample version
and this is the with the pop is the
population version
right so
you
want to see how they relate to each
other
and you can take the um
centers
of the centroids of the
eigenvector decomposition of the
laplacian
and
take a look at that
so
this is
the projection of the first two
eigen directions of the laplacian from
data
and you have the centroid
here and here
and you basically looking at how far
the how far apart the central is
relative to the vision cluster tightness
and this is the quantity you're looking
at
the wheezing cluster
distance
ratio 2 cross
cluster distance that tells you how well
things are separated
and you can show that actually
this actually doesn't depends on tau so
from the point of view looking at the
impact of tao it doesn't make any
difference and the top can be rewritten
as the eigenvector matrices between the
sample laplacian and the population
application
and with the
davis and can't have a perturbation
theory you can now bounce because this
just disappear doesn't depends on how
i'm only changing in the impact of tau
becomes the difference between the
laplacian
between the eigenvectors of the fashion
this is the spectral norm and the second
eigenvector the eigenvalue
which
measures the um
and this
eigenvalue decreases with tau because
when ta is large then there's no
signature you cannot separate
then you have a bond which is not very
useful
and with something a little multiple
using the
concentration of matrices in olivia you
can show that
there's this more precise bound than the
rough bound you have
the
eigen value
for the from the first cluster and the
second column
so um
a better bonds can be obtained using
some more refined techniques in blush um
like schnans i thought paper from 2011.
so if you unpack this result for the two
block stochastic block model you see
that
we don't need to put uh
constrain on the
minimum degree of
expected degree of the nodes we can get
away with the average expected degree of
nodes
that you'll be able to recover the
clusters so that's the effect you push
down the small clusters and for two
classes you get a big cluster right of
course you get a small class right but
in general you're not so lucky you able
to get the major classes correctly not
the small clusters
and we don't need a minimum degree
assumption
so from the statistical point of view
the most interesting is actually the
how do you select the number the
regularization parameter right now you
introduce a smoothing parameter
are you
going to be able to find a data driven
way to do that
so what we did is that we take advantage
of this radical bound
and come up with the data-driven
criteria to do the selection
so the idea is that
we just look at the quantity which come
out in our upper bound which involve tau
which is the regularization parameter
and here
involves a population quantity which we
we don't have any access to
instead
we're going to use the model stochastic
block model or later actually also works
we even don't have the theory worked out
we think it can be done or degree
corrected stochastic block model to have
a parametric model and then use that to
estimate
this population version we have a
surrogate unplugging and now we just
minimize this statistic
it's the upper bounds the estimated
upper bound and that's our data driven
regularization parameter chosen
okay so it's pretty simple idea using
the upper bound
and if you do that
then you see that you do improve
you simply
you basically have
using the output from the regularize for
any fixed tile
you have the clusters using the regulite
sc
stochastic classroom algorithm and then
with the classroom you can ask me easy
stochastic block model without that it's
kind of hard to actually still have a
model
same time with the classroom you only
have the estimate parameter so the
second stage is pretty easy
and then you use
this probability
to estimate the population version
laplacian
and the eigenvector
and then so for each child on a grid you
now have a quantity
and you can optimize
and that
you end up with another run of the same
uh stochastic block model things a
little tighter and then you can do
that's what's
chosen by our data-driven method
and again k-means
won't be able to
accommodate this kind of
um and overlapping in this direction
and we also messed up a bit with
regularized version but much less
okay
so it's really reducing the variability
that's what regularization does as in
many other
situations
okay yes does it make sense to iterate
to
after you do this three again
so into which stage for fixed tile
so
i re-estimate the population
after you have the towel
we haven't you could
we haven't
because it's pretty heavy already
computation-wise
because you you do many many uh k-means
and
like a special classroom
i think
yeah i don't know whether we improve or
not but computation wise would be even
heavier
so for the political block data
so this is from
this paper and being used a lot in
community detection people already
labeled
the
blogs as conservative blocks or libra
blocks
and you can see that there are few kind
of outliers
and if you use spectral classroom they
will really
hide the big clusters at least for the
leading eigenvectors
if you look at the degrees it's kind of
the parallel
and
you look at unregulated special
clustering the first and the second
bigger vector you don't really see a
separation
okay
because it's dominated by these outliers
how did you get the edges what where did
the edges come from
oh they are just linking to each other
to refer to each other
yeah
so is it
is it cement right so it's summarized we
didn't do that direction yes this is
summarized because i'm not dealing with
a direction so there's a link one way or
the other we just call it a link
so the second vector
basically end up concentrating on
discriminating this small
cluster from the rest it doesn't really
tell you it's major cluster
and but the third eigenvector
that's differentiate the blue from the
red
so you can also think of the
regularization as shifting the order of
things and now that you concentrate on
something which is hidden in the third
eigenvector
and lift it up to the second
and if you do the regularized chosen bar
measured tau being 2.5 you can see now
the second eigenvector already
differentiate the two main liberal
blocks versus conservative blocks
and um
but i should mention that um
the
one of the authors of the regularization
paper iu chen
in personal communication told us he
also tried using the modularity girvin
newman modularity and use that it works
pretty well too
but it was not they didn't put in the
paper
so that's another alternative method to
do this we did compare if actually if
you simulate from stochastic block model
our method works better but for the we
only tried one two uh data set the
results are pretty comparable
so if you have really like stochastic
block structure because our model really
assumes um estimators don't has a block
we have an edge but in terms of when you
don't have that
something like stochastic block model in
your data then
with the limited experience we have the
other the other idea from ie also works
pretty well
just looking at the girvin newman
modularity and then compare that for
different types
so we have that in the paper i think we
did comparison in the paper
so back to
the
fate map
you can see that this unregulated
spectrographic is being pulled like
in this
political block model that
you have this tiny
kind of clusters
that dominated
the leading eigenvectors and
skilled the big clusters
and if you regulate you get a more
sensible uh segmentation of the embryo
which much better with the fade map than
this one
and the summary
is that
there is
you can interpret upper bound as
something like
bias and varying tradeoff the difference
remember the bond you saw a couple of
times also the motivation for
regularization parameter selection
the difference between the eigen
like the spectral distance between the
sample laplacian and the population
laplacian it's like variance
and you have downstairs the eigenvector
which is like a eigenvalue is like a
bias
and
if you take a log of that you have like
more like
log variance price log by so there's
that trade-off which you see a lot in
regularization literature it's always
playing this trade-off so it's kind of
there too in a different form than what
we used to l2 like just by squared plus
variance square variance
and
we find our threat to analysis have a
practical implication in the sense that
we can select the regularization
parameter even we didn't do this theory
we believe it can be done we also try to
use degree corrected stbm
in the estimated population of fashion
and it works better because it's more
flexible in practice
and for
fruit fly
image segmentation
it seems promising and the paper we have
a revision
2014
at this website and what's going on for
the project is that
we want to go to the later stage for the
embryo
to find out where are the organs
and for special clustering
as i mentioned to jerry that we need to
fast algorithms now it seems quite heavy
computationally and we think that the
regularization has a nice correspondence
with this level set idea started from a
heart against work it's really kind of
giving you a level for what's the level
of cluster you want to look at
and
for continuous data i think would be
interesting to get the theory done for
the regularization
parameter selection thank you so i think
um
data are
is the time of development the same for
all the images or different times of
development and that's actually um we so
far
use human manually matching the stages
right now would be great to have
temporal
because it's development right but right
now the highest this is a high
throughput data we have the timestamp is
very coarse
there's some better data for fewer gene
expression from michael biggins lab
which is more continuous but for the
high throughput with 700 genes we only
have very rough
type of and then it's eyeballing we kind
of humanly put them together
and that's another thing if we can do
segmentation better that can also help
us to line them up better so so right
now we're assuming they're lined up
but later you want to have a kind of
inner loop
right use the organ development stage
maybe help us to line up yeah
we're not there yet yeah
so it seems like the graph must be
relatively small
before you can do that because that
would blow up your memory
but you know putting in the complete
graph
so you must do some either the examples
are small but the other way of course
would be to put an expander or a random
graph
yeah of low weight but then i think
there was a bunch of papers that did
that i think in image processing i think
some of uh
of matt um malik's students did that
student medic okay i thought they used
they added random graph connections
for the large crops
right
yeah for me my my graph is relatively
small i have like a few hundred pixels
pesos you're adding in all edges right
but i think theoretically you're adding
in all pairs of edges right no but
that's right hold it so it's pretty
sparse yeah but still but it's still all
edges it's not sparse it's it's still
dense graphically already no but i
because i have correlation i cut it at
ninety percent of the
the edges below ninety percent i set it
to zero
are they sampled with those
probabilities what the edges are
actually sampled with those
probabilities
when we didn't sample we just cut it
right so you calculate all pairwise
correlations and then you cut a 90
percentile and the ones below 90 percent
we just set it to zero
but you send this off to uh something to
find the
the feedler vector for you right
at some point you need to compute an
eigenvector yeah
so that's done on with the regularizer
added yes
then you you dance again you're right
yeah
yeah and so what i was proposing is to
use a random graph instead right
so you would random you were random it's
like the edges yeah just randomly put in
edges because theoretically that should
have the same effect okay yeah we
haven't tried maybe that's how we speed
it up
right and then i think there's other
older work that did that
so alex recommending some of alex
students okay
okay i'll look do you remember when was
that
i don't know right after they did the
spectral classroom
paper of that i think she i think she
was at cmu at the time i forgot to know
okay i'll chase after that thanks
computation is an issue i mean these
eigenvectors are completely iteratively
so
you know at every iteration you only
need to compute the a times a vector
and it's a rank one perturbation so it's
the order you never construct the full
matrix yeah you just do a times b plus
one one transpose b yeah but if there's
a billion sizes then that's not going to
do very well that's not i mean all the
amount of stuff we always do is inverse
power
yeah that would be inverted power range
another theory would do for power you
lose one or your convergence but then
it's order right and you don't have the
problem of constructing the full nature
then you have to do some multiple event
iterations right what's great what
depends on the gap
but if you theoretically if you do
inverse power and then you only knew log
n and log n direction well here it
depends on the get right so there are
variation it depends if the gap becomes
larger actually you can
i just yeah definitely follow up with
you guys i'm
the computation we just used pretty um
basic
like r type of thing
how big or how big are you for me it's
just a few hundred
because the pistol was sweet originally
much higher precision but we had super
pistols
but eventually
we like to do higher right but
so i'd love to talk more about that yeah
when selecting the top and you should
estimate the second eigenvalue of that
lesson so
it is possible that this eigenvalue is
not cubed
like in two blocks so you calculate uh
laplacian which isn't true
block
uh matrix right so here it's symmetric
oh you mean the estimated one yeah yeah
the the first value should be positive
but the second one is not guaranteed to
be positive so what do you mean the
estimated version yeah yeah version so
when it is
i think we haven't it hasn't happened in
real data with us
but in theory you're right because he's
worried that the estimates the cashier
block model might not be symmetric
no but even
yeah you worry about if you're symmetric
then you have positive eighteen volume
because isometrized
yeah but the estimated version of that
laplacian is not guaranteed to be
positive semi-definite
when you plug in the
parameter estimates
any other questions
script blender
so in all your examples the two clusters
that you're dividing they seem to be
comparable in size
so in some other instance of clustering
sometimes you want to cluster a fairly
small cluster to separate a very small
set from a very large set well does that
regular change when you so i think
that's what say i think what
intuitive i think what the
regularization does if you look at the
fake map they're not always the same
size
so in some sense you kind of cut it at
somewhere only go for the ones above
that threshold
so i'm not worried that if your one
cluster is much smaller than the other
you introduce all sudden you introduce a
lot more we just don't we push the small
cluster down and we don't see them so so
you're right that would be a problem if
you really want to go for the small
clusters
right then the regularization will
obscure that
are there other methods of regulation
that might be promising for you well the
thing is the chicken acting right for
classroom anywhere if it's very small is
that noises and no it's not very clear
unless you have a prior information to
tell you that's a real cluster it might
just be noise right
so so i think in other prime information
have to come in
so if you just add a product on the b
rather than
yeah that's what the other line
quite similar
but what i hear from that group is that
it works better but i don't have
first-hand experience
they think it's better than doing both
that's what the same
it's similar you just regulate what's on
the bottom
i think the analysis car rose group did
that it's quite similar
i don't think the theoretical analysis
would tell
you it's better but in practice his
student tells me that it's a little
better
during that way but we haven't tried it
is the opposite
no i mean the one from peter's group
yeah so so then maybe it depends then
well i haven't had we haven't compared
uh
i think for our data i think it's quite
similar yeah
but i did hear from the other group
these things better but
i haven't uh have first-hand experience
so maybe
yeah i'll put you in touch with them and
you guys can figure it out one
yeah
yeah exactly
but to figure out when
and why one is better
than the other
but i don't think that sometimes the
analysis really tell you that
strong course
not detail enough
good thing thank you